Progress of the Machine, 1673, Hugen's Cube, 1695, Hopin's Pot, 1700, Savory's Machine,
1705, Newcomen's, 1765, James Watt's Machine, 1770, Cuneo's Trolley, 1801, Travathic's
Machine, almost a locomotive. 1829 in England, the Europe of the Vienna Treaty was at peace.
Napoleon's defeat at Waterloo was the event that gave Britain its supremacy.
Look here now.
That little island was soon to rule over more than 240 million people.
So when is it finished?
Sir.
Here we are.
Thank you.
Maestro.
Mr. Stevenson, I suppose.
Hello, hello.
It's right this way.
Thank you.
Sir, if you don't mind.
Why don't we stop here just for an instant?
Of course.
That thing over there seems very interesting.
It's prodigious.
Really.
That's what I call progress.
And believe me or not, within no time at all, all those engines will work with steam.
You mark me.
That's it.
Ah, very well.
Gentlemen, good day, good day.
My son, Robert Stevenson.
And, uh, well, here's our marvel, the rocket.
The social order had moved towards the industrial middle class.
It was mainly to their profit that business was good, that factories ran well, and the
steam engine worked.
There was a lot of competition to find work, and even those who did find it lived in poverty.
Chins up, we'll win with our locomotive.
You'll be seeing me in a high hat in no time, and things will go a whole lot better for
our little family.
So long until tonight, children.
Hi Papa!
Only this way.
Yes? It's this way.
Maestro, pleased to meet you. I'm David Gordon, and, um...
Here's my latest invention. Fantastic. What?
Yes, it's not bad, but it doesn't interest me.
Oh, well, then you must see my latest invention.
And this... this marvel, it works, it does.
How's that?
Oh, really, that's not for me.
I am versatile and versatile in here.
You are going to be carried away.
Perfect.
You come, sir.
Maestro, my name is Goldsworthy Gurney.
And this is my motor.
Not bad. It's a good idea. Well, it works quite well. Fantastic, young man.
He stipulates that all vehicles must be preceded by a horse for a man carrying a large red flag.
And that is what I call a wise decision.
This ordinance is idiota. You're holding up progress.
It wasn't for several years in 1833 that Lord Ashley could get the bill passed forbidding the employment of children under nine
and restricting work hours to 13 for children from 9 to 13,
only in the cotton industry.
Elsewhere, more than 50,000 children, less than 13 years old,
continue to work in England, in the textile industry alone.
Me, my good friend, why are they all shouting?
The union delegation looks like they're off petitioning the town hall
to ask for improvements for work conditions in the factory for manual laborers.
Those are new customs, sir.
Most unspeakable, sir.
What?
It's an out-and-out obstruction to liberty in our work.
Thank you, sir.
It was only in 1842 that England passed a law preventing women and girls and boys less than 10 years old to work in the mines.
Same year in France, there was the interdiction to employ children under 8 years of age.
The 6th of October, 1829, in Liverpool, there was a big competition for railway engines.
There's no good reason to believe that those damn machines will ever be of any real utility.
Alright
Already seen
Burstall and Hilsand
I wonder how they'll get on
This time
Eliminated
Then the next
Well here's
The One and Only
By Mack Worth
Eliminated
The Novelty
By Braithwaite
And Erickson
What?
Sit to the next
Stevenson's
Let 30 people
Board my machine
Climb on the wagon
Wait for me
I'm going
Pardon
Wait for me
I'm interested
I wouldn't miss this
Now bring up
The pressure to maximum
Ten miles an hour
After ordering two rockets from Stevenson, Maestro was to return to France, where serious events awaited him.
July 1830, people were to raise the barricades to get a monarchy more liberal than the retrograde one of Charles X.
Hot up in the movement, the Belgians revolted and proclaimed their independence on October 1st, 1830.
Everywhere in Europe, the oppressed people were stirred up.
England, railway triumphed without some difficulty.
Public order is disturbed.
Yes, and the cinders are setting fire to our harvest.
Yes, our harvest, and our property too.
Yes, all the smoke is poisoning our livestock.
And us too.
I demand they construct some walls high enough to be able to block out those horrible engines.
And I protest formally that no railway be built near the university.
And so in 1842, when the young Queen Victoria wanted to borrow a train,
a daily newspaper warned the Queen to be less daring or run the risk of causing a great national catastrophe.
In 1937, the first French line, Paris-Lopèque-Saint-Germain, was inaugurated.
The railway was not accepted any better there than in England.
It'll never be more than a child's toy or an amusement for the Parisians, prophesied Monsieur Kier.
Those locomotives will end up by exploding.
And Arago, one of the most eminent men of science, said,
Rapid passing from one climate to another will surely have a fatal effect on the lungs.
Pregnant women will have miscarriages.
Or soldiers will become effeminate.
The new industries, the machine, upset the economy.
The country people moved into the cities.
And the population grew in Europe.
There wasn't enough work for everyone.
Father, thanks for what I got to do. It's not worth it.
All right.
Why the alcohol?
Well, why?
Is there anything else to do?
There's work to do.
I've heard of a great railway underway not so far.
I'm sure there's lots of work for you and me.
Oh, that would surprise me.
But why? Our trade is working in iron.
Ah, you might be right. We'll try it.
that fantastic look at all those men working look you want to give me some hand money maybe move on
doesn't it look like a beehive it's fantastic shelter sappers have blown out a huge block of
rocks that was blocking the way the train will run right over the bridge did hear that you hire
men where will you work with me to the depot i'll take care of this something tells me that you're
hard-working men during louis philippe's reign it was no longer the absolute monarchy in france
it was the absolute bourgeoisie all reforms were vetoed and revolt was no joking matter
nevertheless society was booming personal stairway is at your disposition in spite of its problems
session of images will be the cause of serious inflammation of the retina
the smoke and the cinders are causing our lungs to get infected
frog vibrations are causing nervous disorders and are encouraging hysterics in our women
The serious part of traveling by rail is all of those drams.
And look at these beautiful covers.
That's to buy one of these to cool you.
Oh, me, I'm interested.
That's six foot.
There you are.
And this, listen, absolute marvel.
One might say it's the invention of the century.
And with this, a voyage is like staying home.
Huh?
Well, nobody's buying.
I bet this object will interest you.
Look at these cushions.
Lovely for your back.
Me, I'd like to buy one.
You'd like to buy a cup of tea?
Why, of course.
And you? And you, mister?
No, thank you, no, King.
Let's see.
And this?
Ah.
Look at this.
You could buy all kinds of alcohol.
The latest action for menfolk,
and mirrors and plenty of sweet things.
Little conveniences for women.
And these braces to hold their trousers up.
Curling irons, pastries, jams, and jellies.
You're sure to find everything you could want to buy.
Sure, sir.
Here, now, at last.
Yes, it's not bad, but I can't be too sure it will go.
I've got it.
Well, now, like that, and so, this time, it'll work for sure.
In the year 1842, we bring the horse-drawn tram, and also...
Let's go.
Me, what is it?
Let's see.
What's the matter?
You rotten machine.
You always are the best.
With some time, my good friends.
That's our slogan.
1847 was a year of famine.
In Ireland, hundreds of thousands of people died of hunger.
There was mass emigration from England to America and Australia.
France and Italy were on the edge of revolt.
In Switzerland, civil war followed national reforms.
The first Communist Congress was held in London, where Engel and Marx drew up the manifesto,
Workers of the World Unite.
1848, in France, Louis-Philippe's government still refuses any kind of reform.
The 23rd, 1848, another uprising in Paris.
He has abdicated and fled.
The Second Republic is proclaimed.
And together, citizens, we'll build a society that's equal and just.
The flag was red, but only as far as the Champs-Élysées and the flag tricolour has gone around the world
with the name, the glory, and the liberty of this country.
In about a few days, the spirit of revolt had spread abroad.
Countries of the German Empire, Baton, Hess, Nassau, Württemberg, Sachs, Hamburg, revolted.
The beginning of March, Austria's turn.
The Hungarians, the Czechs, demanded their liberty.
The 18th of March, uprisings in Milan, Venice, Palermo, Modena.
The same day in Berlin, the barricades go up.
The early spring of the people blossomed in Europe.
The emperor of Austria fled to the Tyrol.
But his army remained loyal, and this steamroller was soon to start moving.
17th of June, Prague is retaken.
25th of July, the army of Piedmont is defeated.
In August, with the help of the Russian army, they crush the Hungarian government.
In October, Vienna is taken.
In France, the government is made up of bourgeois who deplore socialism.
With the National Workshops affair, there was the outburst of working-class riots, crushed severely.
22nd to the 26th of June, there were bloody battles between the rioting workers
and the forces of law and order, leaving thousands dead.
Harsh reprisals followed.
Until then, we had the workers and the bourgeois on the same side of the barricade.
But that was over now.
The Constitution rejected the right to work, to education, to public welfare.
The people had once again been robbed of their right of dissent.
And why?
It happened only to the urban workers.
Terrified the peasant who elected the majority in the assembly.
I swear my loyalty to the Republic.
Furthermore, there was still a great antagonism between the different ethnic nations that were barely emerging.
But the seed had been sown.
Until tonight.
Don't be late.
The limit for trains was now 120 kilometers an hour.
There's no stopping the railway from progressing in giant leaps.
1856, Napoleon III is emperor of France.
And the clever Cavour sends a female ambassador to plead for the independence of Italy.
The emperor, being a gallant man, would listen to her cause.
1856, a skull is found at Neanderthal in Westphalia.
Man or monkey?
The church was shocked by the alternative.
In 1859, Darwin publishes The Origin of the Species.
This time, there is a storm.
But your grandfather or your grandmother was the monkey manure, sir.
With the help of Napoleon III, Italy is liberated.
Cavour, Garibaldi, Victor Emmanuel II work hard to unite Italy.
My baby.
Germany is still divided into 38 states.
Before long, with fire and blood, Bismarck will forge them together.
In the United States, where Lincoln is president, there is the war of secession.
The attack on Fort Sumter, between Victoria's England, is at its height under Prime Minister Palmerston.
still developing. When a mountain could not be spanned, it was dug into. 1864, in the Dordogne,
on an inner wall of a grotto, paintings were discovered. This time, the alternative was clear.
Either the monkey who did the artwork was a great artist, or man and mammoth had coexisted.
Karl Marx published Das Kapital, the Pan-American. The parts of the different ends,
two railway trunks, had run for 300 kilometers without meeting. Finally, their junction in 1869.
The same year, the Belgian Graham invents the dynamo.
Electricity wasn't far off.
1870, the Franco-German War instigated by Bismarck.
Fire and blood, German unity.
To the defeat, there was the commune of Paris and more victims in one week
and during the entire French Revolution.
1876, Graham Bell invents the telephone.
At the rate of 10,000 kilometers a year,
railway in less than one century will spread over 400,000 kilometers in Europe,
more than 1 million kilometers in the whole world.
Lifeline of the peoples of the world.
- Would it bring them closer together?